your house as a fine little house Jack  are you allowed to speak along the way I  was thinking there might be rules let me  put it this way ray if you make it all  the way without uttering a word but do  carry on I really just don't believe  you're going to tell me something I am  third before I was maybe a mistake what  was my mistake me getting in this car  with you you might as well be a serial  killer sorry but you do kind of look  like one  [Music]  [Music]  [Music]  some people claim that the atrocities we  commit in our fiction are those inner  desires which we cannot commit in our  controlled civilization so they are  expressed instead through our art I  don't agree  I believe heaven in hell are one in the  same the soul belongs to heaven and the  body to hell  [Music]  when I think about all the things I've  done in my life  without in any way resulting in  punishment  [Music]  [Music]